Michael Hauge: That’s pretty much for both
the outer journey and the inner journey level,
how Stage 1 and Stage 2 work.
Now we come to the second key turning point
in what I call “The Change of Plans.”
This is the moment when the hero has now formulated
the goal they want to achieve.
In his case, he’s going to get the best
plea bargain he can get for these defendants
and they begin pursuing it.
Now the point to notice if you’re a screenwriter
or a filmmaker or even if you’re a novelist,
that whatever the outer motivation, whatever
this visible goal, your hero is going to pursue,
that defines your movie.
Your hero shouldn’t start actually pursuing
it and taking action to cross that finish
line until the beginning go Act 2.
You’ve got to take entire 25% of your screenplay
just to build up to your hero taking those
first steps.
Everything up to now has been him gathering
information to figure out “What are we going
to do?”
It’s only when he takes that first step
of going to The Bay that he is now moving
toward the goal.
And this is Stage 3 in what I call Progress
because his plan is “Okay I’m going to
get the facts and I’m going to juggle them
around and figure out a way that I can get
them off with the least sentence possible”
and that is when he meets another key character
in the story and that is his Nemesis.
That’s my term for the person who is at
cross-purposes with the hero.
If the reflection [character] is there to
help the hero, then the nemesis is going to
stop the hero from achieving his goal.
He’s the one in opposition.
He’s the villain.
In this case he’s more like a villain but
he could be an opponent if it’s a sport’s
story, or it could be a rival if it’s a
love story or a romantic comedy.
But it’s somebody who goes against the villain.
And when we meet Jessup (Col. Nathan R. Jessup
- that’s the Jack Nicholson character),
a few things are apparent immediately.
One is, he is way way more powerful than (Tom
Cruise’s character - Lt. Daniel) Kaffee
is.
This is a must!
When you’re writing a screenplay or a story
of any kind, you always want your nemesis
to exceed your hero in their power and abilities
and strengths and so on.
It must seem like it’s going to be impossible
for your hero to overcome the Nemesis.
So Jessup has all the power, all the rank,
he puts Kaffee down.
Kaffee is sort of meek with him and shy and
just wants to get out of the situation.
He seems almost wimpy in the face of Nathan
Jessup, which is exactly as it should be because
now we’re involved.
Now we realize the conflict is big.
And the bigger the conflict the more our emotional
involvement is in the story.
So he starts working and working and working
toward (Kaffee does) figuring out or putting
together defense for them.
Now on the inner journey level, remember he’s
got this tug-of-war going on be between his
identity, his safe persona that keeps him
stuck in a place that is familiar in his comfort
zone but he’s not going to lead to any fulfillment.
And (by the way) I don’t think I mentioned
this, the rule is, if the hero doesn’t move
into his essence, if the hero is not able
to shed his identity and have the courage
to live his truth, he cannot achieve the goal.
He doesn’t realize that at the point of
the story, he thinks he’ll pursue this goal
so he can keep his identity in place.
But it will always follow because you (as
the writer) are going to make it this way.
But unless the hero finds the courage to leave
his identity, he’s not going to get that
goal.
So now, your hero is vacillating, moving into
his essence a bit because he’s got to in
order to move closer to the goal.
But that becomes very scary because he’s
lost his armor or his emotional protection
is gone so then he’ll retreat and go back
into his identity.
So you’ll see when you watch the movie (or
if you watch the movie again) as you watch
this during this stretch, Kaffee is at times
going to seem like a really good lawyer.
He’s going to do smart things he’s going
to figure out things, he’s going to know
how to manipulate things (not Kaffee but some
of the other characters).
He’s coming up with ideas, other times he
just wants to back off, get a plea bargain
or whatever until finally (when he realizes
his defendants are not cooperating at all)
he says “I can’t understand these guys,
I’m going to quit.
I’m going to get the lawyer replaced.”
And he makes that threat right before we reach
the next key turning point, what I call The
Point of No Return.
Question for the Viewers: What is the Point
of No Return in Aaron Sorkin’s movie A FEW
GOOD MEN?